إيران لا تسعى
لامتلاك سلاح نووي أه لو أردنا
صنع سلاح نووي
لكان بإمكاننا فعل ذلك منذ فترة
لكننا قررنا
أن الأسلحة النووية
لن تزيد من
أمننا وتتعارض مع آرائنا أه
الأيديولوجية
ولهذا السبب  لم نسع قط إلى أسلحة نووية
لكن صحيح أه
أن وقت عودة الولايات المتحدة
للسلاح النووي للاتفاقية النووية ليس
بلا حدود ،
إن فرصة الولايات المتحدة محدودة
لأن الرئيس بايدن لا يريد
أن يصور نفسه  نظرًا لمحاولة
الاستفادة من السياسات الفاشلة
للإدارة الرابحة السابقة ،
تحتاج الولايات المتحدة أولاً وقبل كل شيء إلى
إنشاء أحزاب
بونابرتاؤها للعودة إلى الاتفاق النووي ، فإن
الولايات المتحدة ليست
في الصفقة النووية وليست في الاتفاق
النووي
بسبب  وقرارها
بالانسحاب
دون أن تسلك الطرق التي كانت
متاحة لها في
إطار الاتفاق النووي ،
ومن ناحية أخرى
استخدمت إيران الآليات في  الاتفاق النووي
من أجل الحد
من تعاونه إذا قرأت الفقرة 36 ، تص
فنا بما يتفق بدقة مع
لاتفاقية النووية الآن عل
الولايات المتحدة أن تعود إل
الامتثال وس
كون إيران جاهزة لل
د على الفور ، فالتوقيت ليس هو ال
ضية  المسألة هي ما إذا كانت
الولايات المتحدة سواء كانت الإدارة الجديدة
تريد اتباع
السياسات القديمة للسياسات المدفوعة
لإدارة ترامب
أم لا ، تم التفاوض على الصفقة النووية
بناءً على ما يمكن أن نتفق عليه وما
لم نوافق عليه
هذه هي الصفقة التي تم التوصل إليها.  على
الولايات المتحدة أن تقبل
ما اتفقنا عليه قررنا عدم
الاتفاق على أشياء معينة
ليس لأننا أهملناها
ولكن لأن الولايات المتحدة وحلفاءها
لم يكونوا مستعدين لفعل ما هو
ضروري
هو أن الولايات المتحدة مستعدة لوقف
بيع الأسلحة لنا.  المنطقة
هي الولايات المتحدة مستعدة لخفض
مئات المليارات من الدولارات من
الأسلحة التي تبيعها لمنطقتنا
هي شارع موحد  على استعداد لوقف
مذابح الأطفال في اليمن